as people in Gaza prepare for Ramadan
their excitement is mixed with tension
for many cousins the Muslim holy month
is a time to come together with family
and friends to break fast and share
meals but for some the memories of
conflicts and Wars when they've
previously celebrated are casting a
shadow
we want to feel the joy and happiness
that Ramadan brings to our homes and our
children we have many sad memories but
we will not tie them with Ramadan it's
not fair to make this month a month of
Sorrow
we have prepared all essential foods and
dates for our customers during this holy
month we know it's difficult time and if
any escalation breaks we'll have to
store all these food and lose a lot but
we hope it will be fine and people will
enjoy Ramadan peacefully
bite this most cousins are preparing for
Ramadan with the same enthusiasm and joy
they have every year families are busy
decorating their homes shopping for
special foods and buying gifts for loved
ones
what you see behind me is called the
colored neighborhood by the people here
they've painted pictures on the walls of
their homes to celebrate and welcome the
coming of the holy month of Ramadan
life has been in stapling Gaza for many
years with ongoing conflict and frequent
outbreaks of violence Patrice intentions
have been particularly high with
fighting between Israeli forces and
Palestinians in the occupied West Bank
and East Jerusalem and that sparked
fears of a wider conflict Hamas I
believe with the mediation of Egypt and
other Regional and international
countries has been restrained from
escalating the situation with Israel but
let me also add that if Israel keep
pushing against the Palestinians and
Nablus engineering and within Al-Aqsa
most that might lead to a very limited
escalation with with Israel which might
not last very long
the International Community has
repeatedly expressed concern about the
rising tensions in the occupied
territories the United Nations has also
expressed concern but about the
potential impact of any conflict on
those in Gaza whose lives are already
precarious
Al Jazeera Gaza